well today i have a very special guest
um his name is ben patrick
and if you have knee pain or
back pain or whatever i mean this guy is
the guy
to learn from he's known as the knees
over toes guy okay so um
i'm actually i sign up for his program
and i swear my lower back is just
feeling incredible so we're going to
talk to him today
i mean this guy has
orthopedic surgeons critiquing his
videos like all positive he has uh
coaches of olympic teams talking about
his work he has pro athletes physical
therapists
really impressed with his work so
welcome ben uh
to this interview well thank you for
that intro you're too kind maybe i can
hire you to do my my intros always wait
i'm available i'm available to do that
look i've been a fan for a very long
time you've done a lot for me so
hopefully i can return some value today
awesome
well today i want to really talk about
knee pain because uh your your rehab
program is quite remarkable i just want
to tell you you don't know this but um
a while ago i had uh my back has been
killing me and of course you know in
high school i was training incorrectly i
was in a wrestler went to wrestle in
college and i i did everything wrong and
blew out a disc um and ended my whole
career and so
every time i try to start to put weight
you know put like do some deadlifts and
things and put a lot of weight on that
disc it just blows out for at least two
to
14 days so
i decided to get an mri and uh
nothing showed up no protrusions nothing
my back was actually intact so
so then i stumbled on your stuff and i
started to
use your um kind of discoveries on the
on the knee but actually for my lower
back and
you know walking backwards doing the
sled backwards oh
my goodness did that work like a charm
so i want to just pick your brain and
share because there's a lot of people
listening right now that have not only
knee pain but
um they sit a lot
they have low back pain and your stuff
is just
dynamite but i want to first start just
like what does it mean uh knees over
toes what does that mean
so the
the reason for the knees over toes name
is because
a big myth started about 50 years ago of
don't let your knees over your toes
and so for me coming up i was always
told that but i had disastrous knees and
a partially artificial kneecap by the
time i was 18 couldn't play basketball
anymore and i never trained with my
knees over my toes
but
the moment you
want to step down stairs or jump or land
from a jump there's intense pressure on
your knees over your toes and that was
the only conclusion that they found 50
years ago is when your knee is over your
toes there's more pressure on your knee
but it didn't determine that was a bad
thing it just determined there's more
pressure there so we'll be able to dive
in and look at
that's how you reverse out knee pain is
actually by figuring out how to safely
apply pressure so you can handle that
wow so um i'm sure you know i've read
your your books and uh um
basically the the methodology of how
they train us now
in
high school junior high school
college professional i mean it's just
like it's incorrect it's totally
outdated so you you basically you had
some serious knee pain i think
early on that led to a surgery
and um
then you had to kind of like dive do a
deep dive to figure this out yourself
tell us a little bit about that yeah so
my chronic knee pain started about age
so i didn't even
quite develop right
i worked so hard to be good at
basketball in terms of the skills
but i just didn't have the body and i
had knee pain starting at 12. so by the
time i was in that 18 to 20 range
my knees were a mess i had no
muscles around my knees to protect them
couldn't play basketball anymore
and i already had a i have a dead guy's
meniscus i have a
some some kind of plastic substance for
a kneecap in one knee
um
my my quad tendon that even like holds
things together had to be surgically
repaired that was actually all on my
left knee and then my right knee
i still kept trying to play basketball
even though i didn't get any college
scholarships or anything like that
then on my right knee i i was diagnosed
with a torn acl had more tears so at
this point i was like
i was just completely at
the bottom with my knees
in my mind it ruined my life
and at that point i just
gave up basketball and was like if i
could just figure out
how to have healthy knees how to
bulletproof my knees
and so then i just went on a journey of
that and it was kind of fortunate that
one side was full of surgeries and the
other side was torn up but i didn't have
surgery and i was even though i should
have had surgery i was too
depressed on i was like no way no more
surgery so those two very different
knees
actually made my journey a lot tougher
to work my way out of it because
surgeries can leave things really stiff
after
but then non-surgery leaves it like too
loose there's not it's not connected
so
this gave me actually a really good
starting ground to figure out a lot
about the knees and that is the
fundamental principle i figured out is
that all the attention on athletes to
get faster and jump higher and
accelerate forward forward forward
we actually are super imbalanced and
we're too weak backward and we don't get
enough
training backward and that actually
restores the circulation and the
strength so that's the the foundational
principle is just how do you get
stronger backward
you know i just want to bring up a point
because a lot of my
philosophy is
opposite of mainstream which makes total
sense so here you're trying to get
forward forward forward and go backwards
so um
you know yeah
i know and i'm doing um i'm not only am
i going backwards but i'm doing this i'm
pulling the sled up a hill so i'm living
on a farm right now and i'm actually
using the hill
and uh you talk about
taking it to the next level pulling a
sled
up a hill
about i don't know 100 yards
that's the best workout on the planet i
mean you get cardio it's just my knee
you know what's interesting and i want i
want you to
explain the difference between eccentric
and concentric because we're we're
working like the eccentric muscles
and uh there's there's less soreness
like i'm not getting sore like i would
the other way
you just want to touch on that just a
little bit
here's a good way to explain it simply
if someone has seen
a backward sled drag
and my editor's amazing he'll be sending
visuals and so we can look at all this
on screen but
a backwards sled drag would be like the
fundamental starting point 200 meters of
backwards slight drag now in your case
you have a hill plus a slide so let's
not try to envision that yet let's just
envision you've got some smooth turf and
you're dragging a sled backward
even if i
mistakenly loaded the sled with a
thousand pounds you'd be unlikely to get
hurt it just wouldn't move whereas if i
mistakenly put a thousand pounds on a
squat bar
and then you bent your knees
you'd be almost guaranteed to have
catastrophic injury so both of those
positions
allow you to train the strength of your
knees
but with the sled there's way less
chance of injury you can also get into a
rhythm where you can't exactly lifting
weights you have to be a bit more
cautious and take you can't just like
start pumping out and getting into a
rhythm
so we not only have the safety but we
have the circulation
kids have this just incredible
circulation they can heal everything in
their body and as we get older it gets
harder and harder to heal our body so
that's the first thing that backward
sled starts establishing is it starts
strengthening our knees and then the
second thing it starts establishing
though is the circulation because we
also probably have to heal stuff it's
much easier if you're a kid and you have
no injuries you have no pains now you
get older you have certain pains and
injuries and you're trying to strengthen
so you have this like this double whammy
at you
and so the sled allows you to kind of
solve both those issues
the only reason i'm doing it up a hill
is because i have no area and this piece
of land that's flat
it's like it's up and down it's valid
what's that a hill is valid and i just
wanted to explain that i just wanted to
explain the sled by itself yeah the
reason the hill so when you when you
actually work backward up a hill that's
much safer than going down the hill so
if you think um so many of the people
who do my program they love hiking but
they start my program because they can
no longer hike like it's too painful for
them to go down hill
so going downhill is too painful but
a hill
is a valid replacement for a sled
because it provides resistance but you
get to control so even if you went
backward up the hill and you took one
inch steps fine fine you just made it
backward up the hill and then you would
go down intentionally slowly and take
small steps so you don't you'd ideally
want not a mountainous hill but a
a smooth safe hill not something jagged
but this would be putting in the work to
get stronger so like in your case by you
putting in the work to go up that hill
you would be more protected than someone
else of the same characteristics if you
both had to go down a mountain and
actually like survive going downhill
it's so true because when i'm
when i get when i take the off and
i'm like
with the hook up for the sled and i walk
around it's like wow i can go down go
down the hill so much easier i feel more
stability for someone in their
50s 60s 70s that are older
mention about um the right level you
should probably just start walking
backwards right without anything
walking backward is a definitely a good
start
and
everyone could find
so we covered a sled so someone
listening someone listening to this has
a sled at the gym and they're going to
go oh wow i can start dragging that
thing backwards 200 meters before each
workout to get the circulation going
someone else listening is going to go oh
wow i have a good hill i'm in florida no
good hill
and it's raining but we have a sled
now if you have a personal treadmill i
wouldn't advise using a gym treadmill
because they might not appreciate it but
if you have a personal treadmill
then you can actually put your butt
against the handle and you and don't
turn it on and you use your own strength
to spin the belt backward and about five
minutes of that is going to equal
roughly what we would get in a
traditional sled workout a lot of people
have gotten their way out of knee pain
and gotten stronger and jumped higher
and things like that just from that we
call it a reverse dead mill backward
dead mill because the treadmill is not
turned on
you could even put your treadmill to an
incline perhaps and put it on like the
lowest speed
some people have said that works so some
treadmills go to an incline
you could put on the lowest speed turn
around and the treadmill's nice because
you have handles right there you can
balance
so
there's
when you when you really start working
at this as i have for a long time and
trying to figure out solutions for
people
there's quite a few good alternatives
you could even with a partner you know
these um resistance bands are super
common super easy to get and so even if
you had a flat surface no weights no
sled no treadmill you can take you know
if you have enough length of band or
what i do is i take two traditional
round bands tie them together and then i
put it around my back and a partner puts
it around their back and we can actually
go 200 meters each way but you do it you
have the the person resisting going
intentionally slowly and then the person
the person working is trying to be very
controlled but you can get some
resistance and get stronger backward
that way so that would be a quick
rundown of options that's a big so so if
someone has um um pain
upon walking when you walk backwards
you're using the opposing muscles and
you're really um
you're creating symmetry it would be
you're creating more symmetry because
there's an imbalance right
yeah
yeah the body is designed to work right
so if we go with that principle okay the
body was designed to work right so where
have we deviated and most of us have
gone after all kinds of pursuits or
accumulated pains and injuries and then
we didn't restore
the opposite of the pain or injury or
the opposite of what we were trying to
achieve so that's the foundation just
gives us the balance gives us the
circulation to heal our body is capable
of doing
some pretty powerful healing on its own
but it has to have the right inputs and
things like that oh my gosh i mean even
me i would um i always had this uh
thought that it was it's really hard to
evaluate myself i need someone external
to go let me see what's going on i can
evaluate other people all day long but
so
my thought was i just need to really
stretch my psoas and that's really the
problem but when i saw your stuff i'm
like wait a second i have to develop
these opposing muscles since i've been
sitting behind my computer
for a very long time
and
i'm not creating enough strength on the
opposing muscles i would i was really a
big biker so i would do biking right i'm
talking like hills
oh my gosh you get off that bike and
your back is killing you because you
don't bike backwards
so
you know it's so when i saw your stuff
i'm like wow this this finally something
does make sense here and then
obviously i'm like watching
what you can do you can dunk you're six
one
and you you still conduct it's
incredible i'm six two
there's no way and heck i can ever dunk
i would maybe someday i can do it if i
keep doing this
um and then you also you can do this i
think
the splits right yeah i can just i can
dunk and i can do the splits and so it's
pretty uncommon to have both of those
abilities but a lot of people can dunk
but i reached my 20s having never even
been able to grab the rim so it's very
unlikely for someone who can't naturally
dunk
to then 10 years later be not just
dunking but like
easily dunking every which way
and so my past coaches are like
what that when they've been interviewed
they're like
what the heck happened this guy went
from you know not even be able to grab
the rim to now throwing down all kinds
of dunks so that's a that's an unusual
thing for that to occur
but
it's unlikely through these last 10
years that anyone has done as much
strengthening backwards as me so when i
go to jump my knees are capable of
handling so much so i can go jump with
full effort just like the young person
who hasn't had any pains or injuries yet
so that's allowing me to give i tell my
body hey i want to jump higher but if
there's knee pain or weakness your
body's going to hold back
so it's almost like
you can get strong enough backward to
handle a force forward it's still going
to be a math equation i can i can drop
from all kinds of stuff but i couldn't
drop from 100 story building so it's
still a math equation of life but we can
we can adjust these by the inputs we put
in
i hear you it's like
when i was in practice i would work with
a lot of people over the age of 60 and
they some of these guys would start they
they're in the mentally they're still 18
and they're they go into crossfit
with very poor training right and
they're they're just they're over
training like crazy they blow at a joint
and it's over it's like they'll pull
achilles tendon right i mean that's like
and now now what now you're gonna let
that thing heal for i don't know how
long and of course the way they're going
to rehab it is not going to go backwards
they're not going to work the opposing
muscles
it's just devastating so
it's incredible just
how much incorrect information that's
out
there incredible and it's
it's all understandable each piece of
data that's incorrect or that prevents
us from healing it's understandable how
the initial conclusion was come to oh
that's a tough position let's completely
avoid that but completely avoiding that
means we're relegated some of us to
lives of painkillers surgery so i was
already on that that track because i
beat my body up so hard at a young age i
was already hooked on painkillers in my
teens
so i
quite literally reversed my way off
painkillers
and
you know that turned into a career i
wasn't expecting that i was just trying
to get out of pain
so
i think that there's some powerful
methods but they do take correct
techniques it's not it's not necessarily
easy but it's usually simple
so i think that's something that someone
first has to realize okay this might not
be easy i may have to find a safe hill i
may have to find a good sled you know
what my local gyms they might not be set
up for it because they've already set up
a certain way for the bodybuilding
muscles and so on and so on so it might
not be easy but usually the solutions
are pretty simple they take a little
more learning and understanding versus
just instantly running the moment
something seems tough
totally
um let's let's pull up a little clip and
maybe you can just kind of
give some
some pointers on like
how someone they should focus on what
they go backwards you know some basic
principles or things or or uh tips or
rules that they should be thinking about
when they start this
exercise
beautiful start intentionally slow
that's that'll be number one start
intentionally slow
then when you're walking backward you're
actually gonna think
with your toes first
so when you go out today and you're
taking a walk you're walking heel first
you're sort of when we walk forward
we're sort of just
tossing the force into our bodies the
moment you go backward you're not
stepping heel first you're stepping toe
first so with each step
you're actively strengthening versus
just passively receiving your body's
weight so every step backwards is active
you're pushing through your toes
and
so those are your first two start
intentionally slow think to push through
your toes then start thinking about
smoothness meaning
we're in a position on each step where
we have pressure on your knees but
pressure inherently isn't bad if it's a
jarring pressure we can't handle
landing from something too high that's
how you get hurt so this is now our
chance to fight back and get it stronger
to handle life's forces so you want to
do it smoothly so start intentionally
slow push through the toes go smoother
now over the course of 200 meters and
you could do more but i feel like it i
feel like you need in your case you're
doing the hill plus a sled so 100 meters
would probably be quite a burn um but
the point is that you're not just taking
five or ten steps we're talking 100 plus
steps here we're talking a lot of steps
so as you start to get into a rhythm and
as you can feel the circulation
increasing it takes more time for the
blood flow to get to the tendons so our
muscles can pump up easier you can grab
a weight and do curls you can get a pump
easier than it is to get blood flow to
your knees so the tendon holds the
muscles to the bones so those are the
areas that usually hurt it's not usually
your
your thigh muscles not that someone
couldn't have thigh muscle pain but knee
pain we're usually not talking about the
muscles we're talking about the things
trying to hold us together so those
tendons they take more time to get blood
flow to them so give it some time start
intentionally slow toes first
be in a smooth rhythm then as the
circulation starts increasing don't
think if you're using a sled to just add
more weight start to step even quicker
so now as you step even quicker while
staying smooth
this really ramps up the burn and what
it does
if you imagine dragging 100 pounds
backward and if you increase the speed
of the step while still being smooth
your muscles and tendons would be
working very hard whereas if you just
added more weight you might start to
just kind of lean back more so if you
just if you just keep leaning your body
weight back are you really doing more
work so it's a very interesting exercise
because it's not
it's not
all about the weight you're usually
looking for that nice medium amount of
resistance no resistance might not give
a burn too much resistance and you might
not be able to get a natural smooth step
so this your step you should be able to
get into a natural step and so like in
our gym we don't keep increasing the
weights we have male and female weights
that roughly work we can adjust them
down if needed we don't go more
we just step quicker as it goes until
we're just gliding
really gliding and exerting
all out so the ideal set finishes at
like 10 out of 10 exertion but without
any pain which is awesome because how
many of us as we get older
we would like to exert all out but
there's so much chance of injury in that
so this is a way that we can exert all
out kids are out there on the playground
with they're not pulling hamstrings when
they sprint they're just
all out exerting themselves and not
getting hurt so this gives us kind of a
foundational exercise that we can exert
all out without getting hurt
yeah so
so what i'm what i'm getting is that you
got to get the technique down got to get
the so you're not going too fast too
much to and then hurting yourself i'm
thinking of
my guitar teacher right guitar teacher
he says no no slow it down get the form
down don't try to go too too much and
then you end up it sounds terrible um
but the point is like
so i think um you just gave me a good
tip because i'm if i'm going what i what
i was doing is um there's no way i could
run up the hill backwards i can't do
that
and it's not that's not necessarily safe
right so i'm going backwards i'm walking
but then i get to a point where
i can't go anymore right it's like
there's no more i i can't even that's
good
that that is the end
thing that we're going for is that you
really exerted your body
so it's interesting the way we the way
we reverse out these knee pains and get
more youthful it's by figuring out how
to work hard we have to exert and let
our body know hey this is a young body
we're trying to exert all out here
so the more we just tone everything down
down down and don't exert
that actually doesn't preserve the body
the body decays faster being sedentary
doesn't make you live longer it makes
you live less long but how do you exert
like that without the injuries along the
way so it's it's a pretty unique
exercise of getting stronger backward
it's so active it's so much effort but
it's fundamentally safer and you get a
lot of benefits out of it so that the
next time in the next time in a year
later you're more protected
and then when you're going backwards
are you
you're what muscles are you working more
of compared to going forwards
so
when we go forwards
you're
basically having to
pull the ground beneath you
and then extend the legs so you do when
you're going forwards you do have a lot
of hamstrings and glutes and
and it doesn't mean you don't also work
those when you go backward but
you're not getting when you're going
forward like that you're not getting
much stimulus into these muscles that
get closer up to the knee and when you
go backward
now starting with your starting with
your feet and then some shin muscles are
working and now there's a vastus
medialis muscle which is like this
teardrop shaped muscle by the knee
that's the one that contracts first when
your knee is under load so rather than
just receiving the impacts now you're
actively getting that vastus medial
stronger the vastus medialis
relates to less knee pain so
you're able to proportionately get more
development i would basically say
from the ground up starting with there's
a bunch of muscles in your feet
most of us are locked up in shoes that
aren't really designed like a foot is
shaped and then in our training if we're
doing leg presses the foot is flat if
we're doing leg extensions well the
foot's not even
pressing against anything squat's
deadlifts the foot is flat so all of a
sudden going backward we're loading
right through those feet so we're
getting stronger through the big toe and
the arches and the achilles and these
lower calf muscles and then coming up to
these muscles close by the knee and then
there does seem to be some effect
of strengthening
in the psoas but in a sort of stretched
position because you're having to now
move the ground beneath you
in the opposite direction so if you
think if you reach your foot back and
now you have to move it that way so if
people look up what the psoas is that
you're talking about a deep hip flexor
muscle in there which is often related
with the back
if you just stretch it some people
actually can can see reduction of back
pain by by stretching it but if you're
not telling your body to get stronger in
it then i don't know if you're quite
telling your body like hey i need a
really youthful lower back here so
stretching it alone versus actually
getting some loading circulation
strengthening in there
there there are implications that the
backward works for back pain
scientifically it's barely been explored
um but but even whatever they have done
it's like oh wow
it was noticed that back pain improved
so that would be kind of my first guess
is that we're balancing things out we're
getting tremendous circulation we're
strengthening some muscles that maybe
we've never actually loaded and
strengthened before
when you um
you know you do the sled or you're
walking backwards
is there some type of rule of thumb of
how much backwards versus forwards
the the rule of thumb is at least as
much backward as forward so
sleds have traditionally been used for
forward and i think when you i think
when you apply the same intention of
start intentionally slowly with a medium
amount of weight that resists you but
it's not too heavy not too light you get
a lot of cool benefits from going
forward with the sled too and you do
strengthen up those glutes and
hamstrings and things like that so
going forward this slide is awesome but
like we have a rule in the gym you're
never allowed to do more forward than
backward you have to do at least as much
backward as forward and so like
currently
currently in the program we have right
now i just have four workout days per
week someone could obviously do extra on
wednesdays and weekends if they want and
mondays and thursdays we go forward 100
meters and backward 100 meters and then
tuesdays and fridays we just do 200
meters backwards so if you're looking at
weekly volume we're talking about 600
meters backward and 200 forward
incredible
as far as the balance between
flexibility and strength you had a video
on that topic i maybe you can touch on
that just a little bit
we can break it down now better than
i've ever been able to break it down
because i was on some long flights the
last couple days and really figuring out
how to explain
how to train for longevity how to train
for youthfulness how to protect your
body
and if you think of this podcast if
we've covered one main thing of going
backwards so far and getting stronger
backward
this would be my next main thing that i
would consider extremely important so
if we think about a child
we don't see a lot of i mean my my kids
won and it doesn't seem like he's
throwing us back out yet so
if we think about throwing our back out
i can even it nothing's happened to me
in a long time but i can even relate
before i did this training sometimes i
would throw my back out like
picking up a pencil or like getting out
of the car in an awkward visit like it's
not like it's not like the forces around
me injured my back i injured my own back
from within my body kids don't
injure their own bodies from within
their bodies like kids don't have
non-contact injury it's but
children are weaker and so they're
constantly getting hurt by the
environment around them they're not
strong enough so if something falls or
hits them or bangs or so as we get older
we get stronger so we're
we're more protected from the
environment but we lose that mobility
and so we're more likely to hurt within
ourselves
so it would seem that the way to train
for protection would be blending the
mobility and the strength
so that's
i use the sled to warm up
pretty much every other exercise i do
even before stretching
oh yeah we walk into the gym and this is
this is a interesting point i want
someone to realize
okay the fact that i can dunk is only
significant because i couldn't naturally
do that so i did something in my
training that changed that the fact that
i can do the splits i think is only
significant because i don't spend hardly
any time stretching so it's like wait a
second who does the splits with hardly
any time stretching yeah the reason is
because my strength exercises
are through full ranges of motion i
quite literally maintain a front splits
through two different strength exercises
a full range of motion split squat and a
full range of motion basically a
hamstring type deadlift that if you
actually add up the angles i can do the
splits any day of the year and i don't
spend time stretching for the split so
that's why it's interesting because
there's not many cases or any that i've
seen of someone who can do the front
splits who doesn't stretch to be able to
do the front splits i only strengthen
but i'm not doing traditional squats i'm
not doing traditional deadlifts my
squats and delts in our way through full
range of motion so my flexibility is
exceptional but it's not just
flexibility because i'm strong through
every inch of that flexibility so
this is why i can do
i film just about every day of the year
landing from things getting into crazy
positions i simply have a more youthful
body because i've more
but i can also dunk because i've tried
to i've tried to stay so dedicated to
this idea of strength
through
length
meaning not just strength not just
stretching the kid has the mobility
the
the power lifter has the strength but
they're both getting hurt the power
lifters hurting himself the kid is
getting hurt against the outside world
so if we blend those qualities now
you're less likely to hurt yourself and
less likely to get hurt from the outside
world and as we age we lose strength and
flexibility so we just become totally
fragile it's like again it's a double
whammy against up so the sled restores
the circulation think how many things we
have against us as we age
we get stiffer we get weaker and we lose
circulation so the sled starts getting
the circulation getting us balanced so
that we can even get into deeper range
of motion exercises safely and that's my
system in a nutshell we use the sled
before every workout that's it we come
into the gym we use the sled to get
exceptional circulation and balance
going then we train all the traditional
areas that you would train we press and
we pull and we bend and and all these
things that squat and that all the
traditional things you would do
none of them in the traditional way all
of them really controlled through our
full range of motion this often means
starting over
with super lightweight or no weight or
negative weight of using things to
assist to even get into these positions
and that signals to the body
that motion and compression through
these full youthful ranges that's
actually what tells the body to signal
more healing send more nutrients to the
area try to get younger so we're all
somewhere but we all could probably
adjust our training to be more youthful
more protected than what we currently
are i'll tell you my goal is to get
younger as i get older so far it's
working but now i want to
you kind of inspired me to take it to
the next level so i'm going to
keep doing your program until i can dunk
that would be something that like a
first
and then about a week the internet would
break
yeah i think the internet would break
well i would i would love to do that and
then i'm going to um i'll be i think
either 57 to 58 next week so um i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna keep doing the
program
incredible
see if i can uh
do that with uh your advice of course
but
um for those of you watching i'm i'm
definitely um you need to sign up for
his channel and do his program it's an
online program i'll put a link down
below you guys should check this out not
just for
knee pain
goes way beyond that it's like you're
building your foundation like
very few people work on the lower part
of their body it's like it's all just
like oh yeah i'm gonna go to the gym and
work the upper part they neglect
not only the lower part but in the right
training so you get the flexibility and
the strength what you came up with is
actually
so remarkable and it's simple
makes sense so i appreciate you
discovering the stomach illness
unfortunately you had to go do it
because you hurt yourself but if you
never hurt yourself
and you never probably had that surgery
you probably never would have forced you
to figure this out
well thank you and yeah best thing ever
happened to me now i'm
able i'm able to just play with my kid
and go dunk one every weekend i get to
play basketball and it's it's
you can't even imagine
i couldn't even imagine the joy that i'd
be able to get from a weekend pickup
game with my friends and be able to
throw down reverse dunks like i'm an nba
player or something so
and now my goal is to dunk when my kid
can dunk so he's won so this is my my
entire training goal every workout is
calculated how am i gonna dunk
when i'm 50 and the program has to be so
good that of course he's gonna have to
dunk cause he's not gonna have the
genetics to naturally dunk so i can't
that's that's my that'll be my greatest
moment in my life will be dunking when
my kid can die
totally is it you think it's possible is
there hope that i could maybe dunk
someday
i think i think there's hope everyone
starts out at different heights so at
six two if you could get probably to the
levels that
not necessarily in in the events that
they're doing but if you look at
master's athletics so you people are
training for masters long jump or master
sprinting things like that
if you could get to those type of joints
and kind of put all those
characteristics together though the
uh i think it would be possible i'm
gonna go for it
love it so so i will do that video and
see if i can pull it off but um
thank you so much this has been awesome
and
for those of you watching definitely
check this guy out it's like awesome
stuff so thank you so much
thank you hopefully i was able to return
some value today
absolutely